欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这一章节我们来学一下怎么样去做店铺诊断
构建一套属于我们自己的诊断框架逻辑
很多时候不是说我们不知道怎么样去优化店铺
而是因为我们根本就找不到店铺存在什么样的问题
所以我们才不知道怎么样去优化
如果你找到了问题
那么我相信你一定能够找到
对应的方法, 去解决这个店铺的问题, 但是呢, 大部分人, 都是因为没有思路, 不知道去判断什么指标, 这些指标, 能够给我们反馈出, 店铺存在什么样的问题, 从而导致了, 我们经常都是, 这里操作一下, 那里操作一下, 操作来操作去, 都捉不住核心的问题, 没办法针对性的解决, 所以才会导致我们店铺好像, 做了很多操作,
但是效果不尽如人意, 所以我们一定要去学习诊断的一些思路, 去构建一些诊断的框架, 那么我们去找问题的时候, 就会非常有针对性, 而且判断的更加的准确, 采用更加合适的方法, 花更多的时间, 在这个核心的问题上面, 那么我们这个店铺才能够快速的改善, 关于这个店铺诊断这项技能,
是每一个运营, 摇摇的要学会的
这一章节,我主要讲的是思路, 加一些分析的维度
因为这些才是决定着你能不能找得到问题
以及找到了问题之后, 如何去分析
只有有了思路之后, 你再用我们前面所学的各种方法
去针对性的解决对应的某一个问题就可以了
那么接下来我们一定要重点学习思路跟分析的一些技巧
一定不要小看这些思路
一定要重视起来
然后去多练习
去构建一套属于你自己的诊断框架
那么接下来我们来看一下第一小节
首先怎么样做店铺诊断更有价值
我们在开始之前一定要把这四个问题要弄清楚
我们做店铺诊断的目的是什么
就是要找到店铺存在的流量, 转化, 订单等问题, 并采用具体的方法去解决问题, 来提升我们店铺的货客盈利能力
那么在诊断前,我们必须来思考这四个问题, 能够更快的帮我们找到店铺存在的问题
第一个问题是什么呢?就是你的店铺有没有买家禁电? 如果你的店铺连禁电的买家都没有
那么你就去考虑为什么我们的店铺没有循盘
那么这是不是就断层了
所以说你找问题就没找的对
如果连买家都没有
那么你就不应该考虑有没有循盘的问题
而应该考虑我要如何去做
才能够增加我店铺的点击跟访客量
这才是解决问题的关键
所以说我们要看点击跟访客的数据
而不是曝光量
曝光量并不是真正的访客, 所以一定要重视的是点击跟访客这两项数据, 必须要重视
第二个问题就是买家进店了, 那么讯盘转化怎么样, 订单转化怎么样, 也就是买家很多, 给你发的讯盘有可能就是很多, 但是订单少, 这种情况也会有这种情况
另一种情况就是, 进店的买家很多, 也就是访客跟点击非常多, 但是讯盘非常的少, 这种问题又怎么样去解决
是不是按照这种逻辑去思考, 接着就这个到这个维度, 再到这个到这个维度, 也就是循环到订单的这个维度, 那么循环多, 订单少, 又怎么去解决呢, 所以我们看到有循环转化了, 还要去判断这些循环的质量高不高, 质量决定着你的整体的一个订单的转化, 所以它们是相关联的, 你看, 我们讲的这些问题, 单单从这几个问题, 就能够去判断出我们店铺当前,
处于哪个阶段,哪一个维度是出现了问题, 然后针对这个维度的问题再去找到具体影响这个维度, 结果的那些指标, 或者是说我们的一些具体的产品, 其他的更小的维度去分析, 那么才能够真正的解决问题
第三个就是买家从哪个渠道来的, 前面我们已经讲了很多个流量来源, 那么你要知道你的店铺的流量来源都有哪些
他们是通过什么词进来的,准不准, 这一词, 是吧, 如果不精准, 那我们怎么去优化
精准的词, 我们又该如何去调整, 是不是都跟我们前面所学的方法都有相关性
只不过是说, 我们可能之前不知道如何去判断, 如何去分析而已
所以这节课主要是讲如何去分析, 如何去判断
这样你后期, 你才能够不断的构建出你的新的方法
那么这个就是局道的问题
那么我们可以在流量来源, 引流关键词, 一一对应, 去看局道, 去看关键词
然后去判断它的一个精准性和转化效果, 就可以了
那第四个就是如何捉住核心的指标去跟同行对比, 找差异, 找到突破的方向
因为很多时候我们数据一定要去跟同行做对比才能够知道我们做的好与不好
我们不能单独只拿一个数据出来就问这个数据好还是不好
数据只有对比了才能够体现它的价值
不能孤零零的把一个数据拎出来说我这个数据好不好
你要跟你的行业里面的同行平均或者是你同行的优秀数据进行一个对比
或者是说跟你上周上个月的数据进行一个对比
这样才能够体现出你这个数据当前的价值
不然的话你单独的去问一个数据有没有效果
或者是说你问一个数据好不好
这个真的没办法回答你
所以一定要对比才能够产生价值
同时通过对比你就能知道你的差距在哪里
才能够找到你的重点的突破方向
那么这个就是在我们做店铺诊断前
经常要去思考的这四个问题
你只要思考了这四个问题
其实已经能够非常清楚的帮你在你的脑海里面
梳理了一次整体的一个诊断的思路
和帮你梳理了一下你店铺当前正处在哪个阶段
有可能你通过问自己这四个问题
就已经能够有了一定的答案了
我们就是去往更细的维度去分析
就能够快速的锁定问题,解决问题
那么我们的操作才会更有效
好了,这节课就先讲到这里
那么这些思路希望大家重视起来
我们下节课再讲一些更加具体的问题